[Music]
you know out of all of the visual
storytelling media that are out there
film animation television comics is
really the only one that is not time
bound that's what I call permanent which
means that you know when you're watching
a movie or when you're watching an
animated television series the rate of
information flow is actually determined
by the creator of the content it's not
determined by the viewer you know you
could slow it down you could you can go
you can go slow mode but it's not the
same experience comics on the other hand
with comics the rate of information flow
is firmly in the control of the reader
and for certain students and certain
kinds of information that that aspect of
comics that control makes for a very
powerful educational tool in an algebra
2 class that I taught I whenever I was
absent I I would create these comics
lessons for my students and that was
some of the feedback that I got from
them is that you know with these comics
lessons it was visual unlike their math
textbooks but then on top of that the
students themselves can control how
quickly or slowly they read through that
lecture
unlike when I was lecturing in person
right when I'm lecturing in person I
decide how fast or slow I speak but when
they're reading it in in the form of a
comic if they didn't understand a packet
packed a passage within that comic they
could reread it as quickly or as slowly
as they needed to in the past I think
parents and teachers had almost a
hierarchy of reading they saw picture
books as almost the lower form of
reading than pure prose novels and comic
books which is my area of expertise
we're either left out of the equation
altogether or they were seen as like
this this this middle point this the
stepping stone between picture books and
in prose prose books and if you were a
good enough student you wouldn't need
that stepping-stone things are changing
now I think more and more parents and
teachers are realizing that pictures are
can be a very sophisticated way of
commune
getting information back in the olden
days if you look at comics often the
picture was there to to basically
present what the words were already
conveying you know so you would have a
caption that says Superman punches Lex
Luthor and then in the in the picture it
would just show you Superman
punching Lex Luthor right in and I think
that contributed to this idea that
comics were meant for the mentally
deficient if you weren't smart enough to
get the meaning of those words then you
could at least read the picture nowadays
though I think if you look at the the
top comic book writers the top comic
book creators the relationship between
the words and the pictures is much more
complex often they will pass narrative
responsibility back and forth so in
certain parts of a comic or graphic
novel the words will convey what the
most important information is in that
story and then in the next passage it
will get passed to the pictures and and
in the hands of a skilled creator each
of those forms each of those forms of
communication the picture and the words
will be leveraged for what they're best
at there are other comics were the words
and the pictures are actually
contradicting each other they might even
be telling two different stories
describing two different realities and
they ask you as the reader to decide
which one is true I really think that to
engage today's audience today's audience
has has grown up on stories every single
one of us has probably consumed
thousands and thousands and thousands of
stories within our lifetime in order to
engage an audience as sophisticated as
that you need to have a sophisticated
dynamic between words and pictures
[Music]